and I have ala with me again welcome ala
you know it's like it's your usual task
you know you should come to the studio
no matter what and how was how was it
going for you today yeah uh started
pretty good I was in the Le when at
under around 3 4 so but then I lost
against Maxim and then it was downhill
after that yeah that was also crazy game
against Maxim and um so which game you
think was the best one today which you
like the most was a very interesting
game it was a Kings Indian game he was
on the lead with Maxim so was important
for you yes for the standings I mean now
we are playing for second
place with Maxim three how many points
ahead two and a half points ahead two
and half points it's too much so um but
second place is only half a point I
think if I'm not wrong so if I'm not
wrong things were changing every round I
have to check after
Maxim uh but yeah this Kings Indian game
was interesting he doesn't have so much
experience in Kings Indian so I said
it's it's interesting to go for it and
here I'm equalized already because in
the opening he didn't remember so much
so yeah it was an interesting game he he
brought his King out of the attack I
think this to run yeah this Advantage is
maybe a bit fake because I couldn't find
how to break like he brought the king we
were
maneuvering and uh I now my attack
doesn't make sense here so I was looking
at the other side so I still I felt like
I would uh spend some time here he gets
down on time and I push C6 so here he
had like around 10 seconds I don't know
if this is correct yeah yeah yeah this
was crazy moment yes I mean everything
started to hang yeah everything is
hanging and uh here he has to find
Brilliant moves like Rook D5 but I was
lucky I had this B5 thing yes okay
that's an important moment I think
before B5 can we check what was
happening did you see this move yes you
couldn't do I queen now Queen A4 yes
yeah no this I said Queen takes but okay
computer says B5 I hear B5 I mean it's
hard to play like that but I said B5
here is clever but now he says that this
is draw AB Rook C4 yeah because he
believes that there is no Checkmate
which is crazy to imagine yes Queen B5
Queen C3 and then Queen B2 and after
Rook B8 there is something like kn B6
right I mean how can you make this move
still it's not easy D5 D D5 oh my gosh
yeah Rook takes takes takes and this
bishop opens but he
draws it looks completely crazy as
what's happening now you
see2 okay this is crazy this is this
absolutely insane but let's see what
have you how far could you see did you
see this Knight B6 no I saw yeah I
didn't calculate so much I said it will
it was intuition so if it works it works
yeah okay and yeah he couldn't do the
best defense is just low on time in
Blitz is enough this kind of attack yeah
so how do you feel you just mentioned
that you are fighting for the second
place already is there any chances you
know somehow to do it for the first I
mean what what should happen I mean I
should probably win like 0 games
tomorrow too I mean I did it last year
exactly Wonder but still Maxim should
not get six points he should get like
five and a half yeah then I have chances
so it's it's impossible but but you also
play against him so I mean things can
get still well change yes okay that's
great I mean we will see what happens
tomorrow thank you so much ala for for
the interview for your comments and all
the best of luck for you tomorrow thank
you thank you Anastasia and thank you
Ali